do I mean [ __ ] you got songs with
people that
the fact that you were able to have a
kehlani and Janae feature on an
independent project and like you know
that's a big deal man that's what says a
lot about your relationships that you've
built over the years yeah and it takes
it takes Ryan it takes hard work and
especially artists of that statue well
those are also the type of artists that
have high artistic uh Integrity don't
want to work with someone and you can
make the greatest music but they don't
want to work with you if you have any
you know they also like aren't the time
I'm assuming like you just can't pay for
like features from some of these artists
oh no come on
they got to be great for sure it has to
be something that's like yeah I'm gonna
do it most of the time you know those
are artists that'll really just get in
there and just do it and create because
they love music this way I mean it's
weird because I'm in both Industries you
know I mean I'm in the r b and I'm in
the rap and I see the difference I feel
like the r b side they really appreciate
music a lot more and they're less of
like trying to bang out a bunch of songs
and just get in the studio and [ __ ]
I'll put this [ __ ] out they there's a
lot more Integrity behind it you know in
the rap world it's a little more
aggressive like ah [ __ ] it we'll just do
this [ __ ] it's a lot it's a lot more
like fake and toxic and twisted for sure
well I mean like I think like you I mean
nowadays
you know guys like Rod wave are
considered hip-hop and I'm sure like
sure he's got like you know yeah but
it's like
you guys are really just doing like kind
of like your own thing like you know
it's almost like when like people would
consider post Malone a rapper I'd get
like sick when I would hear that out
loud because I'm like he's just an
artist yeah he's an artist
to me you're an artist yeah like you
could rap you could do this seeing
melodic [ __ ] but you're like an artist
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah post
Malone but you know they're and but
there's those worlds like rap world
where it's like like these are rappers
like Doja cat is a rapper technically
she raps but she's also sing too though
yeah she's a pop star bro like she's a
[ __ ] yeah when I say like yo she's
the hardest female rapper I'm like
but then you'll get really look at her
in that lens yeah maybe yeah but you'll
get into those Industries where it's
like this is this is r b this is like
these people are the most r b you could
get like you know that r b [ __ ] is fire
and um I think rmbs have like a dope
like four or five year run of kind of
coming back and yeah
the Soul music side of shits like uh
yeah there's just been some great r b
[ __ ] getting made that's like kind of
like underground but not underground
yeah right it's like shots like
selection radio and apple and stuff they
did a good job of kind of like they've
been in Russian pushing that line yeah
for sure